America's liberal fact Checkers will
crawl over broken glass to try and
correct the Republican but never a
liberal case in point Saturday Night
Live is getting a pass after taking a
bogus shot at former president Trump and
suggesting he made up the term de
banking Trump did have a slight stumble
this week while talking about Banks and
he introduced an interesting new term
called debank we're also going to place
strong protections to stop Banks and
regulators from trying to debank you
they want to debank you and we're going
to
debank I don't know what the hell debank
means but he might have to take D
ambulance to see the doctor the genius
is over at SNL should consult a
dictionary or talk to a trump supporter
debank is a real term and it refers to
Banks closing people or organizations
accounts after perceiving them to be a
Legal Financial or reputational threat
and that's not the only factchecking
fail the left leaning Snopes website was
forced to reverse fact check of what
they did on that Goofy image of Joe
Biden wearing a hard hat backwards they
initially said the story was false but
then people mocked Snopes and they
reversed their ruling to be
true now you know Saturday Night Live
has at least a dozen writers and no one
could figure out that Deb banking was a
real term is their ideology so over the
top that they don't even bother to look
things up Greg I think it was the sunk
cost of writing a joke you know if if
the joke gets a laugh which that one did
and a simple Google search ruins all the
work you put into that Zinger you're not
going to do it and the pro the problem
with this is it's just a joke but you
know po you know politics is Downstream
from culture so you have a lot of people
there who just assume that debank isn't
real it's like it but it is when you
avoid doing the research it's like
getting in your car and turning up the
radio so you don't hear the knock in the
engine it's like if I don't hear the
facts then everything stands and the but
the problem is we can hear it we do have
access to the truth so the joke ends up
being on the teller and on the audience
the other thing is you know it doesn't
affect anyone in their bubble uh he
probably doesn't know about it because
his rich friends are safe and it doesn't
exist if it doesn't affect your liberal
friends imagine the reverse a
right-wing uh comic or humorous denying
that homelessness exists he never would
because you know it's we actually can't
afford to do that if we were to deny
that something existed we would be raped
over the coals but we we also are honest
about it and Snopes in order to survive
has to redefine facts as assumptions and
opinions so now it was just their
opinion that Joe had the Hat on right
when it was wrong but Dana don't you
feel that it you know with the people on
the left now that remember it was like
their Truth versus our truth which could
be the fact or either way and now you've
got Snopes that is reacting to criticism
online that Joe Biden was wearing the
hat backwards not anything that they did
themselves do you remember after 2016
when all the mainstream media sent out
reporters to understand how did they
misunderstand America so much and they
had to write all these pieces well get
ready for them to ride it again and here
will be a great example this actually
did happen to the truckers in Canada
that was one of the reasons that there
was the big protest and the revolt and
this is happening to people uh here in
America the left this is actually what's
weird is that even though they might not
realize it's coming from the left it is
the left's main thing this ESG
environmental social or sustainable
government whatever they call that this
is basically debank is part of the goals
like for example if you own a gun and
you use your credit card or your U you
wrote a check and it's for at a a store
like Cabellas for example where did we
just hear that it was happening last
week yep so president Trump is on to
something and then the media they just
totally miss it it is it is pretty
embarrassing but it'll be fun to read
those stories again next year all right
Jesse Saturday Night Live they've gotten
a lot of things wrong about me in
particular I mean do you think that
they're left oriented I think they got
that
right it's fun to fact check a comedy
show on Fox News isn't
it I mean we are in the front Lin of the
cancel culture War so we know about JP
Morgan Chase what they did to Trump
people or Nigel farage was debanked and
I believe the truckers in Canada got
debanked for that rally they held Dana
you should have brought that up yeah
Dana how did you let that slide I know
you were not listening to Dana what I
thinking about what what were you think
you know what I was thinking about
Snopes Greg because snop said that
baraco Obama was born in Hawaii and now
they said his hat was on properly like
what else are they getting wrong you
can't trust anything they say oh boy
okay we're going to move right on from
that one all right what would you like
to
say nothing about bism for sure
um I think that this is part of the
reason that you're seeing Saturday Night
Live have so much less cultural
relevance and that's not because I don't
agree with the point of view I'm no fan
of Donald Trump but it's such loow
hanging fruit to take something that
you're not even going to do a simple
search he
says so many crazy things that you could
pick have fun with the water and the
magnets or whatever you want but don't
do this because then it also gives
people license not only on on the right
but the people in the middle who are
just kind of sick of the vitriolic
approach to all of this and they just
want to sit down for an hour and a half
on a Saturday night or however they're
consuming it and just laugh and
I think it is telling that the
conversations that we have about Saturn
Night Live where they really have hit a
nerve or pushed the envelope really come
from the monologues like when they have
Dave Chappelle back or when they have
Bill Burr on and they basically say to
the audience we don't really care what
you think about me I'm I'm so much
bigger than this that I'm going to say
whatever I want for the next seven
minutes and the ratings Spike and that's
what folks are looking for and I am very
curious and we'll find out soon what the
impact of the changes in these late
night shows we'll have on John Stewart
when he returns to taking over The Daily
Show on Monday nights it starts February
12th I think um because John Stewart
obviously no fan of trump but also
someone who has given himself to
Veterans causes who shows up here which
I always appreciate and does interviews
um so that's something I'm very much
looking forward to up next dogs aren't
safe in Liberal cities a woman clinging
to the hood of a car to save her animal
hey everyone I'm Emily compano catch me
and my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaye
mechineni on outnumbered every weekday
at 12:00 P p.m. Eastern or set your DVR
also don't forget to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page for daily
highlights